I think the goal of any artist is the
desire to package the metaphysical to
articulate the ineffable to somehow
clothe and capture transients and
ephemerality it is said that artists
step into a metaphysical realm they go
into an altered state of consciousness
they walk into the space of the imaginal
you know liminality is the word that we
use to describe that threshold between
this world and the next between the
ordinary and the extraordinary where the
regular and everyday becomes the
mythological and the artist goes into
the mythological space plato's realm of
ideals and forms truths of poetic
rapture and they do their best to again
package the metaphysical what I think is
most amazing about technologies to
transcribe subjectivity whether it's the
still camera or the video camera or the
pen and ink you know words language
alphabetic rapture that we transcribed
quickly the whirling dervishes of an
active mind into tangible form so that
it can be shared because ultimately it's
about wanting to share the contents of
our minds with others it's about a
desire for a union for closeness it's a
desire to be known and to know another
and the loneliness of poetic rapture the
loneliness of the metaphysical
experience is only a squash the itch can
only be scratched when we're able to
translate that ineffable experience into
language and form and actually share it
with others and then we finally feel
seen and we finally feel understood and
we finally feel have dissolved the goal
of these videos has always been to do
exactly that to take you with me on a
cosmic magic carpet ride and to actually
capture and package the metaphysical
[Music]